une femme pour remplacer Sylvie Faucheux
à la tête de l'Université Paris
Grand-Ouest Anne-Sophie Barz vient
d'être nommée présidente du pôle de
recherche et d'enseignement supérieur de
l'upgo qui regroupe notamment
l'université de versailles-
Saint-Quentin et l'Université de sergie
Pontoise anneesophie Bartès et
professeur agrégé de droit privé depuis
2001 elle enseigne le droit à
l'université de sergis et depuis mars
2012 elle est vice-présidente en charge
du développement stratégique anneesophie
bartè prend donc la succession de Sylvie
Faucheux ancienne présidente nommé elle
rectrice de l'académie de Dijon dans ses
projets l'ouverture en 2013 de
l'Institut d'études politiques à
Saint-Germain
enlayz